[Music]
it's 4:00 a.m. and the big test is in
eight hours followed by a piano recital
you've been studying and playing for
days but you still don't feel ready for
either so what can you do well you can
drink another cup of coffee and spend
the next few hours cramming and
practicing but believe it or not you
might be better off closing the books
putting away the music and going to
sleep sleep occupies nearly a third of
our lives but many of us give
surprisingly little attention and care
to it this neglect is often the result
of a major misunderstanding sleep isn't
lost time or just a way to rest when all
our important work is done instead it's
a critical function during which your
body balances and regulates its vital
systems affecting respiration and
regulating everything from circulation
to growth and immune response that's
great
but you can worry about all those things
after this test right well not so fast
it turns out that sleep is also crucial
for your brain with a fifth of your
body's circulatory blood being channeled
to it as you drift off and what goes on
in your brain while you sleep is an
intensely active period of restructuring
that's crucial for how our memory works
at first glance our ability to remember
things doesn't seem very impressive at
all 19th century psychologist Hermann
Ebbinghaus demonstrated that we normally
forget 40% of new material within the
first 20 minutes a phenomenon known as
the forgetting curve
but this loss can be prevented through
memory consolidation the process by
which information is moved from our
fleeting short-term memory to our more
durable long-term memory this
consolidation occurs with the help of a
major part of the brain known as the
hippocampus its role in long-term memory
formation was demonstrated in the 1950s
by Brenda Milner in her research with a
patient known as HM after having his
hippocampus removed
HMS ability to form new short-term
memories was damaged but he was able to
learn physical tasks through repetition
due to the removal of his hippocampus
HMS ability to form a long-term memories
was also damaged what this case revealed
among other things was that the
hippocampus was specifically involved in
the consolidation of long-term
declarative memory such as the facts and
concepts you need to remember for that
test rather than procedural memory such
as the finger movements you need to
master for that recital Milner's
findings along with work by Eric Kandel
in the 90s have given us our current
model of how this consolidation process
works sensory data is initially
transcribed and temporarily recorded in
the neurons as short-term memory from
there it travels to the hippocampus
which strengthens and enhances the
neurons in that cortical area thanks to
the phenomenon of neuroplasticity new
synaptic buds are formed allowing new
connections between neurons and
strengthening the neural network where
the information will be returned as
long-term memory so why do we remember
some things and not others well there
are a few ways to influence the extent
and effectiveness of memory retention
for example memories that are formed in
times of heightened feeling or or even a
stress will be better recorded due to
the hippocampus is linked with emotion
but one of the major factors
- memory consolidation is you guessed it
a good night's sleep sleep is composed
of four stages the deepest of which are
known as slow-wave sleep and rapid eye
movement the EEG machines monitoring
people during these stages have shown
electrical impulses moving between the
brainstem hippocampus thalamus and
cortex which serve as relay stations of
memory formation and the different
stages of sleep have been shown to help
consolidate different types of memories
during the non REM slow-wave sleep
declarative memory is encoded into a
temporary store in the anterior part of
the hippocampus through a continuing
dialogue between the cortex and
hippocampus it is then repeatedly
reactivated driving it's gradual
redistribution to long-term storage in
the cortex REM sleep on the other hand
with its similarity to waking brain
activity is associated with the
consolidation of procedural memory so
based on the studies going to sleep
three hours after memorizing your
formulas and one hour after practicing
your scales would be the most ideal so
hopefully you can see now that skimping
on sleep not only harms your long-term
health but actually makes it less likely
that you'll retain all that knowledge
and practice from the previous night all
of which just goes to affirm the wisdom
of the phrase sleep on it when you think
about all the internal restructuring and
forming of new connections that occurs
while you slumber you could even say
that proper sleep will have you waking
up every morning with a new and improved
brain ready to face the challenges ahead
[Applause]
[Music]